Gimana caranya berpikir kritis aja kan? Sebenarnya kan itu se general question.
Dari pengalaman gue pribadi kritis itu bukan karakter bawaan.
Kritis itu adalah disiplin. Menurut gue sama seperti lo disiplin menyimpan uang lo setiap bulannya.
Sama seperti disiplin lo setiap pagi bangun lo beresin itu kasur lo.
Disiplinnya kayak gimana sih kalau orang kritis. Menurut gue pertanyakan segala hal.
Apapun yang kalian lihat, kalian dengar, kalian masuk kota kalian itu kalian pertanyakan.
Bener gak sih ini? Kenapa begitu? Kenapa begitu? Start dari satu kata aja tuh kenapa?
Misalkan kayak lagi belajar tentang penjajahan jaman Belanda di Indonesia.
Kenapa ya Belanda menjajah kita? Kenapa ya kok rakyat kita gak ada duitnya gitu kayak diperbudak.
Padahal jangan deh terlalu politik. Padahal Belanda kasih duit.
Itu tuh dimulai dari situ. Kenapa ya? Kenapa begitu? Kenapa begitu?
Dan itu dibiasakan. Setiap kali ngobrol sama orang, kenapa ya dia begitu? Kenapa dia punya prinsip seperti itu?
Dan coba jawab. Coba atau tanya ke orang yang langsung. Kenapa menurut lo seperti itu? Kenapa? Kenapa?
Dari satu pertanyaan itu aja. Tentar akarnya tuh jadi banyak banget informasi-informasi yang kalau kita ngomong-ngomong doang nih yeping doang.
Ternyata itu punya banyak nutrisinya loh kalau misalkan kita gali. Nah itu. Dan itu harus dijadikan habit.
Karena kadang kita ngobrol cuma kayak survey-survey saya gitu kan ringan-ringan-ringan karena kita males mikir.
Tapi coba deh. Have a mentality dimana lo selalu ingin tau lebih dari situ.
Dan itu tuh habit. Bukan karakter. Ya gue orangnya gak mau tauan sih.
Lu gak membiasakan diri lo untuk mau tau. Jadi se-discipline sama seperti aktivitas akitas kita lainnya.
Tapi lo baca buku? Baca. Baca.
Dua buku favorit. Buku favorit. Jujur. Dua buku favorit. Pertama homodeus.
Nah itu kelasik sih kayak kelasik modern lah. Itu jaman Genzi tuh kayaknya suka banget.
Yang kedua itu. Yang kedua itu.
Ini juga ini banget sih. Apa namanya?
Basic banget. Atomic habits.
Itu udah bro. It's simple. Gampang banget di mengerti.
Dan itu impactnya gede banget untuk lo kesaharian. Itu gampang banget.
Itu buku. It feels easy.
Untuk membaca buku yang gak terlalu banyak gitu. Lo baca sampe abis.
Dan kemungkinan lo akan reconsider the things that you do in your life sih.
Ya mind changing sih.
Homodeus dan atomic habits.
Apakah dua buku itu memuntuk cara apaan yang lo mulai lihat dunia?
Dua buku itu punya impact sangat besar dalam pola pikir gue.
Dan aksi.
Dan aksi. Betul.
Atomic habits itu aksi banget.